[Music]
my name is marin borkad i'm professor
for digital entrepreneurship and
innovation management at the exo
exponential university for applied
science and i'm coordinating the
research for the fair work project
the fair work project is funded by the
berlin university alliance and it's
carried out here the technical
university of berlin together with the
oxford internet institute and humboldt
university
and it's about the platform economy
so the platform economy is a reasoned
and rapidly growing phenomenon
um in 2008 it's generated worldwide with
the platform economy worldwide generated
in revenue about 204 billion us dollars
and this is going to double in just five
years okay
the pandemic has shown that demand for
platform work has actually increased in
only um
five months from january to may 2020
the demand for platform work rose by 40
percent
and of course with regard to the
lightning of the regulations you know we
see a small decline but nevertheless
it's going to be more and more important
and people are going to be engaged in it
so what is really platform work think
about all the workers that deliver the
service that you book online okay so
there are two broad categories of
platform work one is a category that is
geographically tethered
to in-person services so it requires a
geographical proximity of the worker and
the customer these are household related
services like cleaning caring pet
sitting this is food delivery every time
you order something for lunch at home or
for dinner there's a person bringing you
the the service bringing you the food
this is related to ride-hailing services
in the city when you book yourself
a cab to the main station right
so these are geographic tethers and this
is what we call platform work besides of
this there's crowd work crowd work is
different crowd work is a work that can
be done online
from everywhere in the world and this is
related to services just as
filling in a survey or training in an
eye system or doing
doing
questionnaires
doing design work doing translational
stuff all these kind of things this is
crowd work and you already realize that
the rights of workers the risks they
encounter are pretty different between
the two major types of platform work
and fair work is focusing on the
platform work that is locally bounded
that is an in-person delivery of a
service booked online
well the main actors of the platform
economy
usually people think about well there
are two sides right there the workers
delivering a service and they're the
customer demanding the services and the
platform is just something like the
technological tool that facilitates the
interplay between supply and demand yet
these platforms are not naturally given
they are human made
they have
they are based on business values
business choices
they reveal relevant insights into
business goals and business strategies
so these um platforms the digital
platforms they really provide the basic
conditions the framework under which
the workers and the customers meet
so they are playing a very important
part in the platform economy as well
for many people for many new scammers in
the city and in this country it's an
easy way to earn it's a fast-track way
to earn money to earn themselves an
income it's a lifeline for those who
face barriers in accessing regular
employment
and very often
so it's attractive for migrants
extractive also for students for example
right and um very often um um both
starts as considering platform work as a
kind of interim solution and a kind of
transitional
stage but then they realize that
due to the barriers they face in
accessing the regular labour market they
stick with platform work and the
disadvantages though
are related to
employment rights very often digital
platform
circumvent or try to to
to
to prevent
workers from accessing rights these are
employment rights like minimum wages
sick pay
regulations with regard to working hours
or even
collective bargaining rights right
but there are also rights related to
social protection like unemployment
benefits
and how do they do this well what we see
in the digital economy in the platform
economy is that they classify workers or
they misclassify workers even sometimes
as independent workers um
letting them assume all the
responsibility
for their health insurances and so forth
so forth so this is something really
that we should think about is this the
new kind of digital entrepreneurship
yeah in the platform economy in the
digital age are these the kind of
working conditions that we all are going
to have to face in the digital age um
are working conditions in germany
deteriorating
or can germany due to its strong labor
regulations
act as a vanguard
to tame for other countries and vanguard
to other countries also in order to tame
the most excessive
expressions of platform capitalism
well the fair work project is uh
focusing on working conditions working
conditions of platform workers and
it's meant to gather insight into this
recently developing and very
powerful new new type of economy
and it's also meant to provide practical
suggestions for how to improve the
working conditions of platform workers
so the fair work project is based on
five basic principles and we are going
to um to provide together information
data with regard to these five
principles and we are going to come up
with a ranking that is related to these
five principles they are pay fair
conditions fair contract fair management
and fair representation so the first two
are related really to the fair payment
that the platform worker receives and to
working conditions that are sales and
protecting their workers health
the third um
principle is related to
the digital platform providing really a
contract and not just terms and
conditions that is often happening in
the geek economy in the platform economy
and fair representation is included in a
management that allows for open
communication channels that establishes
processes um clear and transparent
processes for communications also
between a customer and worker and the
fifth is about
fair representation
and here we refer to collective
bargaining rights to rights of the
workers in order to form the
council and and have a collective body
to show and communicate their concerns
and their necessities
well we have a dream at fair work to be
honest we would like to engage with the
workers the customers
the regulators and the companies
themselves the companies providing
setting up these digital platforms
in order to come up with a fairer
future for the gig economy the platform
economy in germany and the way we are
trying to achieve this is we are
gathering data with workers interviews
with desk research
with this data we are
convening management interviews and we
are going to talk to the owners and
establishers of these digital platforms
about our findings right and we are
going to ask them with regard to fair
pay with regard to fair representation
with regard to fair management what can
you do what kind of data can you provide
us so that we could grant this extra
point
for you and why are we doing this
because we do believe that
research
has an impact in society
so the gather that we are the data that
we are gathering does not belongs to us
into a publication but it also belongs
to the companies in order to provide
them the possibility to improve their
services to improve how they relate with
their with their platform workers right
so and it's also there in order to
inform customers because each of the
customers we all have a choice when we
are ordering food or when we are booking
a ride to the next
station or a party or whatever we have a
choice which platform we are going to
choose and which kind of services we are
going to book so it's all about
transparency and about raising awareness
and getting people into collaborating
towards establishing a fairer gig
economy in general
[Music]
so the fair web project is actually um
the bua you know the berlin university
alliance is made of a consortium of
three universities and this is the
technical university of berlin the
oxford internet institute and the
humboldt university and the three
institutions collaborate together in
order to implement the fairway project
besides this of course fair work germany
is only one small part in an overall
picture
so the fair work project is actually
carried out in 28 different countries
all around the world because the
platform economy is not only a new
phenomenon in germany but it's relevant
in all of the countries around the world
so we have colleagues all over the world
in 28 countries we are collecting data
with regard to
to the working conditions of platform
workers and the idea is of course also
to compare them
the principles is something that we are
going to update every year okay so the
principles with regard to the rankings
of the different platforms are something
that has been
has been developed together with the ilo
and other the unions and so on so forth
you know these institutions who
traditionally are engaged and have very
good experience and and expertise when
it comes to workers right right um but
they have been discussed and and and
worked out for an analog
economy now we are in a digital economy
so we have to take these working
standards these working rights and find
a translation for this new type of
economy right so at the beginning we had
the workshop with these established
institutions
in order to come up with the principles
that are then going to be implemented in
all of the countries and around the
world we just talked about 28 countries
and
with every year
we have rounds of revisions when it
comes to the principles
it's very important to understand that
these are general principles something
like fair pay you know this is a general
principle of course it's related to
the local minimum wage why local because
it changes between country and country
and city and city
besides this we understand that also
what is recognized as the minimum wage
differs from country to country this is
why we established also the living wage
which is actually something more
concrete in terms of the workers life
experience to understand if the money
that he or she earns is really enough to
make it until the end of the month right
so we have these principles that are
going to be contextualized in each of
the countries and the cities that we are
investigating and they are going to be
rise on a yearly basis with regard to
the experiences of all the different
research teams around the world
[Music]
yeah just just
take a step outside
what you're going to see is the gorillas
rider you're going to see the uber
drivers
what you're not going to see are the
services provided
by people
in the households right that are going
to be booked through digital platforms
what i'm trying to say is that um
i think corona has even shown it more
the pandemic has really shown it um
digital infrastructures are part of our
everyday lives um
we
book so many different services through
them right from ordering lunch
or
ordering a ride to the main station
so it's part of our daily lives i think
the pandemic has even shown this more
it's important that we that we
acknowledge that this is
a growing part of the economy
um
there are no
comprehensive or
consistent comparative data when it
comes to how many people are actually
working in the geek economy in the
platform economy in germany
but nevertheless we are talking about
estimates talk about from 500 000 to 1.6
million people
or almost three percent of the working
age populations so this is a this is a
constant number and it's growing
it's important to focus on this topic
because
what we can see from and what we can
hear from the streets from the media is
that a lot of these platform workers um
they are not satisfied with their
working conditions
um you could see it in the recent prose
tests right of riders here in berlin
that make it to the media
last year there was
the amendment of the
transportation services personal
transportation services with regards to
opening up this very established taxi
industry towards new forms of
right-handling uber and so on so forth
free now
so there's a lot of happening in our
cities and a lot of happening in our
economy and society and this is
important to acknowledge it's not only
an economic phenomenon it's also a
social phenomenon because there's people
who are
affected by the working conditions
so the aim of the fair work project is
really to gather information
and approach platforms with this
information in order to provoke change
so there's a couple of platforms who do
like to collaborate with us
who um who are improving on their
working conditions on the working
conditions of the workers in order to
render a service okay to them in order
to improve their situation
from last year's report one of the
effects of impacts of last year's report
is that two of the digital platforms
that we investigated they're in
corporate anti-discrimination guidelines
to to their own business models um so
and this is the kind of impact that we
would like to see because they realized
that a lot of their workers they do have
a migration background so it's important
also to kind of
highlight these issues that may arise
from not being fluent in german having a
contract in another language other than
german not being familiar with certain
rights and the systems in and employment
benefits in germany and so on so forth
so it's very important that platforms
realize
what kind of workforce is working for
them and what kind of needs they do have
and again for this year's protests of
course the fair work researchers were
also present
we observed we
we collected data we collected data also
from the workers
and we are going to approach also the
management and going to ask them what
they can do in order to improve working
conditions okay because this is the
overall goal and impact that we are
striving for
[Music]
so
[Music]
you